two churches one country but two
different dates for
Christmas it's not just a religious
difference in Ukraine it's become a
political
one the Ukrainian Orthodox church has
been accused of having links to
Moscow accusations it
denies but when Ukraine officially
celebrated Christmas on December 25th
last year it was widely seen as a snub
to Moscow and this church was put under
the spotlight
many ukrainians celebrate Christmas on
January 7th we celebrate according to
the Julian calendar and it's been like
that for a thousand years we are not
going to switch to a new style this
calendar is used by Georgian Jerusalem
Serbian and Russian
churches even the service inside is
carried out in old Russian other
Orthodox Churches carry out the services
in Ukrainian we asked nicodem if there
had been any political pressure nobody
no comment
some however are more outspoken against
the official change of
dates sure it's dividing us this is
bullying at a state scale in a time of
War we should be
together ke wanted to unite the country
on one date at the same time as sending
a snub to Moscow president zalinski
wants to show Europe and the Western
world that his country is very much
European and Western and changing the
official date of Christmas to the 25th
of December was in part to display that
but not everyone here is following suit
and there are
divisions on the banks of the freezing
cold Deno River they are commemorating
the baptism of Jesus
Christ but for those who celebrated
Christmas in December today's date has
come earlier than previous
years many people have switched to a new
calendar we should all change many
continue to live in the old ways and
celebrate Christmas in January I
celebrate it on 35th and today for me is
to commemorate the
baptism Ukraine is still at war with
Russia and although keev wanted to unite
the country and distance itself from
perceived Russian Traditions the
divisions run deeper than a difference
in religious
states Assad bag Al jazer
keev make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer